do you remember the first date that you
ever went on like where you went on an
actual date yep
um went Red Lobster I ate some of them
cheesy have you had the cheesy biscuits
from cheesy biscuits yes someone killed
their spouse over a batch of them can
you look that up well I can understand
why did the guy pick you up oh no we
were like real young it was like we went
this is the guy that I dated pretty much
my whole life he was like my childhood
sweetheart so it's like his parents were
sitting at another little booth kind of
like watching us
um but I remember he ordered
crab legs and I remember he he like um
was he a damn mayor
he cracked it and a piece of crab flew
right in my hair and I was so
embarrassed I was mortified I was over
there just enjoying my cheesy biscuit
and that dang crab landed in my hair and
I'm like oh he's and I don't know why
but at 13 years old or however old I was
I was like oh he's not gonna like me
anymore even though he did it to me and
suddenly that's like catching the
bouquet at a wedding you're right you're
right if you get a piece of crab stuck
in your hair yeah that is dang good luck
I know I think you're right
I didn't know to appreciate it then but
I do now that's hot magic yep so that
was my first date
and I think we got that um
yes they have like this big old
chocolate chip cookie Skillet yeah
yeah now that right there I could just
eat that for my meal I remember I used
to write down things on a notepad of
what to talk about when I was like
talking on the phone in high school or
Junior High whatever it was I'd be like
ask him if he caught me frogs while he
was frog giving ask him how many frogs
did he gig ask him did he have fun
I'm like do you not know how to have a
conversation yeah
Lord
but sometimes you don't I think
sometimes you don't know how to have a
conversation especially when you're
young and you're like talking to the
opposite sex and that's right mom would
get on and she would always be like you
need to go clean something it would
always be like what when you were just
getting to the good part oh there was
never a good part but I was just being
alive on the phone with a woman I know
and then oh she always ruined it every
time I remember being so nervous yeah it
was crazy like why
because I think it's just your first
time doing it like you can't even
replicate those nerves as you get it's
like I mean you're you're like you don't
even know what's going on yeah
you're like embarrassed also it is it's
embarrassing yes
you're almost embarrassed of who you are
like how uncomfortable you are yes
that's very embarrassing I remember that
like who am I I don't know how am I dude
what do I do I know and then seeing a
girl at school like or that was always
weird and then you like had to sing
between class so you like and you like
don't know if you need to make eye
contact going down the hall yeah and you
just scream like I love you you just
found something insane yeah speaking of
like like real official dates and stuff
I did not have like a real official date
until a few years ago when when somebody
actually mandolin manager she was
setting up my dates too sitting on my
co-write setting up my dates she
literally told her friend from school
she was like Laney has never been on
like an official like you know somebody
asked you to go somewhere like like a
first date right like an official date
because it's always been like I hung out
with a dude or whatever and then we
would go get some food yeah but it was
nice he showed me what it was supposed
to be like and and did he pick you up
oh you meet him there I met him there
okay because it was a first date yeah
that's kind of that makes sense Kinda
Yeah I met him there but it was he was a
gentleman did he open the door
oh yeah like he walked me to my car and
then then we went and kind of it was one
of those things where we knew neither
one of us we weren't going to date he
was kind of just doing me a favor okay
okay he's like I'm gonna take this girl
out like he knows that I was just too
much for him I mean really oh really
yeah I mean he's just wow what happened
I mean was he small no no no no not
small but like I'm just I'm pretty sassy
are you and spicy yeah I can't help it
really it's just that Louisiana thing
yeah and you know were you violent to or
no no okay no he fed me good oh that's
good yeah you gotta sedate him a little
bit we knew like after we hung out I was
like yeah we'll be friends it'll be you
know when we see each other we'll catch
back up and a good boy who showed me
what it was supposed to be like oh he
showed me that like yeah it's it's okay
to still be traditional I like being
traditional at the end of the day I can
tend to myself like I don't need
somebody to open up a door for me
whatever but every now and then it's
nice to feel like yeah that's that's
very nice yeah I got it for you do you
remember the first time you ever had a
kiss do you remember it yep I had braces
oh we went in kissed somebody with
braces on me
oh yeah that's pretty sick I was pretty
sick bro hey bro yep but oh if I'm
kissing somebody with braces on bro take
me to jail yeah yeah yeah
we were out in a little shop they were
like and what do you mean there's like
machines and stuff like Hammers and yeah
wrenches and stuff hanging on while I
was at my friend Katie's house and her
boyfriend had just left and I thought
tonight's the night I'm I'm going in and
you planned it well I knew it was
happening okay I can just tell how he
was acting like he gonna try to kiss me
tonight so I need to be prepared
but I was a little too prepared because
when I tell you I just opened my mouth
up wide and did this
too I literally was like trying to eat
his face or something I don't know what
like what made me think that I needed to
just do this
[Laughter]
that ain't how it goes it took me a
minute
but it didn't run him off really he
liked it well yeah look if some chick
comes at me with an open mouth I think
I'm gonna figure it out you know but
you're gonna terrify me oh that was
that's spooky that happened to me I was
playing we played spin the bottle in
this girl I loved oh my God and he
messed that up with that kiss
I'm like there's no way she might really
like me and it was like yeah I had the
chance to kiss her and I was like I
remember like leaning forward into the
group and I couldn't even feel my arms
they were like they felt like they
belonged to somebody else and somebody
like who was like like somebody I didn't
even trust it was oh yeah you were just
like rattling dude and I felt like you
could hear my freaking bones rambling
and I'm like oh my God and then I just
and he went in my mouth I'd seen that on
TV I think like open mouth yeah yeah
and everybody was laughing and then I
remember I almost like
I didn't go in like a closet or anything
to oh yeah I'm just gonna do it right
out there and that's that's terrible
they shouldn't have done you dirty like
that God it was horrible man and then I
knew I felt like a fish trying to eat
something and then I felt so sad and
then I remember thinking oh man that's
it
that's it you know and then I saw this
other real creepy dude later that night
brushing that girl's hair by the fire
and I'm like at least I'm not that dead
yeah no that's yeah that guy's a real
creep uh-huh I wonder what he's doing
now I don't know I could imagine time
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one